hi
and welcome to our session ops 203 open
telemetry and observability at shopify
splunk and google
my name is morgan mclean i'm a product
manager at google i primarily focus on
open telemetry as well as a number of
our
ops management products including cloud
monitoring and cloud logging
hi i'm steve flanders i'm a director of
engineering at splunk
working on our observability getting
data in strategy i'm an open symmetry
collector approver
we have a packed agenda today and we're
going to have interesting information
for those who are familiar of open
telemetry
and those who are not we'll begin with
an introduction to the project
what opencelometry is and what the
project includes
then we'll move on to open telemetry and
how it fits into the broader field
of observability after that we will show
getting started guides and examples of
how you can use open telemetry
and finally we'll have stories of
companies that make use of open
telemetry inbound production services
today
open telemetry has a number of different
components and i'm going to start from
the most
basic ones all the way to the core
implementations the customers are using
today in production
to start with we have the specification
the specification is in many ways the
core of the project
it defines the different signals and
different data types
that that you can use to capture
telemetry from your application
for example there's a specification for
metrics that defines
what a metric is what a metric can
capture and how you interact with it
similarly there are specifications for
traces resources
and logs keep in mind that the log
specification is relatively new compared
to the others and so it's still
incubating
next we have a data model the data model
describes
how actual apis and how your code will
interact with this data
and how a metric or trace or log or
other component
is actually described to the to a
computer system
next we have api services these are the
different ways that your code will
interact with the data model
in order to capture correct telemetry
from your application
these api services include
instrumentation which allow you to go
and create a metric for something like
an rpc call
or cat board to define what a trace will
look like when you're capturing it from
a certain source
configuration which allow you to
interact with other parts of the open
telemetry apis and sdks
like sampling for example and finally
there's an api for exporters
exporters are how we send data from an
open telemetry sdk or other open
planetary source
to other back-end components these
back-end components might be the open
telemetry collector which is an agent
we'll get to what that is in a moment
and it can do that through the the
standard open telemetry interchange
protocol
or you can use an exporter to send data
directly to a backend
like google cloud ops or splunk
finally we also defined semantic
conventions the semantic conventions
are not so much rules for the machine
but rules for
people who are defining instrumentation
or capturing data from their
applications
for an example of a semantic convention
would be how to
create a metric for http latency or http
qps
it would include the tags that you're
generally expected to to add there
and the metric names that you would
generate the same is true for tracing
the next level up in open telemetry is
the actual apis and sdks
we have one api an sdk per language so
there are no competing implementations
and all effort is driven behind
that single implementation for language
uh open telemetry
uh as i mentioned has these standard
sdks because we have apis you can also
go create an sdk of your own as far as i
know i don't think anyone is but it's
totally available
for vendors or anyone else to go to find
their own sdk
and the apis allow you to go use
the sort of api services that are
described before to actually go and
write instrumentation or to
interact with the sdks themselves the
sdks contain logic for things like
sampling or creating a trace or creating
a metric and so we generally recommend
that people use the standard sdks and
that seems to be what mostly community
is doing
next we have the collector this is an
optional component
the collector runs as an agent so uh
it uh whereas the sdks you would link
them to your application to go capture
traces and metrics
the collector you would then instead run
on the operating system the collector
generally can't capture traces metrics
directly from your application those
have to be done through the sdks
but it can be used as a processor or
proxy that you send that data to
before it gets exported to your final
destination and it makes things like
configuration a little easier
and it makes just a sort of generally
cleaner easier export path to send data
to your backend of choice the collector
can also capture system metrics so
metrics from places where you can't use
the api and sdk
think of memory consumption or disk
consumption you can do this for windows
and linux
and the collector can be deployed as an
agent on a particular operating system
in that case you also get the system
metrics if you want them
or it can be deployed as a service so
that you can access it and send data
over the network
the collector also contains receivers
for metrics from prometheus
and traces captured from zipkin or jager
clients
there's also some new components that
have been added to open telemetry fairly
recently
these are auto instrumentation agents
for java python and javascript
and we're adding some other languages
soon these will take some of the
functionality you would normally get in
the sdk
like capturing traces from an app and
they are able to perform that
functionality without having to link
link to your application and rebuild it
now they're not
as sort of generally useful as the sdks
the benefit of the sdks is you can go
define a custom metric
or make changes to trace annotations or
or
use the any of the apis natively that
you want to you can't do that with the
auto instrumentation agent
but if you have an application that is
difficult to recompile or rebuild or one
that you don't have the source code to
the auto instrumentation agent is a
great choice
open telemetry entered beta in march
this was a big effort by the community
and we're incredibly
proud of the accomplishments we've had
and this is why you see some
some firms and some organizations
already using some open telemetry
components
in production systems specifically the
march beta included
the java python javascript and go sdks
as well as the erlang sdk and i think
the
net sdk is about to hit beta or already
just has
the beta also included the collector the
beta was very focused on tracing
functionality
and also included metrics functionality
we're targeting a ga later this autumn
the ga will be
prior to the ga we'll have several
release candidates coming out
uh that will be sort of pre-ga versions
and eventually once we're very satisfied
with one we'll declare that as the final
ga version
uh expect those release candidates to
start rolling out later this summer and
the g8
could take place then later this year
okay so let's talk about observability
specifically in the context of open
symmetry
as morgan mentioned there's a
specification which is basically the
foundational part of the open symmetry
project
this specification can be data source
specific so for example there are
specifications for both traces and
metrics
and inside each of those specifications
is some rich information about how you
actually define the information the
telemetry that you're trying to admit
in the case of traces this includes like
the spans and
different attributes that are attached
to those spans in the case of metrics
you have
labels and the ways that you actually
account for the different metrics that
you care about in your environment
you can actually drill into these
they're all on the github repository if
you're interested in learning more
information about them
next we have resources so as the slide
describes every open telemetry signal is
tied to a resource
and if you think about this this makes
sense right if you're capturing metrics
from your application or traces from
your application
they're not particularly useful unless
you know where each metric or where each
span of a trace actually came from
there's different levels of these
resources you can go as low level as the
actual
information that describes the actual
machine that a metric
or trace came from all the way up to
higher level concepts like
services or kubernetes containers or
deployments from which you're capturing
this data
semantic conventions are also extremely
powerful the idea is
how do i actually define this thing that
i'm calling like for example if i have a
rest endpoint or
i'm calling a database if there was a
way to just normalize that information
so it didn't matter which vendor or
backend i was sending my data to i could
still query it out in a unique way
that would be extremely powerful and
that's exactly what semantic conventions
try to do
by offering a standard way of actually
instrumenting you can then
leverage any backend of your choice in
order to query the data out and get the
insights that you care about
true observability now in the case of
tracing context propagation is probably
one of the most fundamental pieces
it's basically how you glue everything
together so when you have your services
service calls
you're actually passing contacts between
those calls you can actually see a
representation of this
on the right hand side this is actually
from the jaeger documentation
basically you call into a service and
you generate context
you then pass that context as you make
other calls to downstream services
within your environment
that context can also be shared within
the application for functional level
calls
but this context propagation concept
actually goes beyond distributed tracing
for example i probably want to share
metadata between my different data
sources
and i can do that through the
correlation context
specification information in addition i
need a way to actually share that
between my apis and sdks and the
propagators is how we do that in the
open telemetry project
there are links to all this information
if you're really interested in learning
the specifics of it
but this is really the magic that glues
all the information together and makes
it extremely useful when you want to
actually query out and get insights from
them
so let's talk a little bit about getting
started with the open symmetry project
the easiest way to do that is to really
start talking about the architecture
so you can see here we have a host
there's an application running on it
and maybe we have one or even multiple
backends we want to send our data to
how would we get started with open
telemetry
well first we're going to go ahead and
deploy the opensymmetry collector as an
agent
the reason why we do this is kind of
twofold one is it can go ahead and grab
the system metrics for you automatically
and send that to the backend or back
ends of your choice
secondarily if i actually leverage the
open symmetry collector as an agent with
the open telemetry client libraries
then it's automatically configured for
me thanks to the use of the otop
protocol that is built into the open
symmetry project
so if i deploy the open symmetry client
library and an agent is already running
there
the traffic will be received both
metrics and traces
eventually logs and all that data can
then be sent to one or more backends
based on configuration rules that i
write in the collector itself
this provides flexibility it also also
offloads some of the responsibility from
the application itself
things like buffering and retry
encryption compression
all that can actually be offloaded from
the application which would consume
resources
and actually be handled in a single
language in the case of the collector it
is go
one way and be handled across my entire
fleet
another deployment architecture is
actually to have the collector running
as a standalone service
that would be typically in the same data
center or region i would deploy one or
more of these collector instances
and usually it's the agent that will
forward to the collector
now the idea here is maybe i want to
limit the number of egress points i have
in my environment so i don't want all
the agents to talk to the internet to
send to my vendor's backend
maybe i want to consolidate the api keys
maybe i want bigger buffer or retry
cues and so i can offload this to a set
of collectors
that i can scale up or out as needed
there are different use cases for this
another one would be around tracing
maybe i want to do tail based sampling
that typically doesn't follow an agent
model you typically need stand-alone
collectors in order to achieve that
and the open symmetry collector is
actually a single binary that can be
deployed as either an agent or as a
standalone service and is very
configurable depending on your use cases
so next i want to talk about auto
instrumentation because
if you've never got started with
instrumentation before it may seem like
a lot to actually get going
and really open symmetry is trying to
make this be as easy as possible
and then later on you can get to manual
instrumentation if you want to add your
own custom
metric or tracing information your own
metadata and enhance what's available
out of the box
the idea with auto instrumentation is
it's basically run time parameter
changes to your application
not code changes so it's very easy to
get started
here's an example of a java application
let's say i have
a java call to a jar the jar that i've
written that runs my application
all i need to do is go ahead and define
a java agent parameter
and point to the open symmetry java
agent all jar file
in addition here i've gone ahead and set
an environmental variable which will set
the service name so i know what this
service actually is and how it will be
represented in the backend that i'm
forwarding that traffic to
that's it i then just fire up my
application and i can go ahead and get
rich trace data automatically for any
supported library
and there is broad support for this
today here's an example in the case of
java of
all the different libraries and versions
that are supported now this slide is
probably already out of date because new
ones are being added every single day
so be it go ahead and take a look at
this and feel free to contribute
additional ones
but it provides broad support and really
can get you started with distributed
tracing information
with little development involvement in
order to get you started
now with that i'd like to show you a
demo of how you can actually get started
with both the open telemetry collector
and with java auto instrumentation okay
let's go ahead and fire up the demo
application
while it starts up here i'll explain to
you what's going on
first we're going to be leveraging the
spring pet clinic microservices
example application it's all based on
java
and it's actually multiple different
microservices that communicate with one
another
as you can see they have a picture on
the repository on
what it looks like from an architectural
perspective
and the applications are actually not
instrumented by default
so our goal here is going to be to add
open telemetry
java auto instrumentation to the java
micro services
and to have them report to an open
telemetry collector
which can then send to the back end or
back ends of
your choice so what i've done is i've
actually modified
this repository i've added a
collector.yaml
which will go ahead and define how we
want the openslimentry collector to be
configured
in this case i'm basically just
accepting over the
otlp protocol and defining an endpoint
where i can actually send
traffic to a zipkin server and
this only needs to be defined once in
addition uh
basically how that spring pet clinic
micro services example app works is
through a docker compose file
so each of the microservices is a
different docker container
i've gone ahead and made the following
modification
basically i've enabled the java agent
runtime parameter which you pass first
right after the java command
and i'm pointing it to the open
telemetry java agent all jar file
and then i am defining a service name
via an environmental variable
so in this case we have the discovery
service and i've repeated that for every
single microservice that's in the docker
compose
you'll see customers visits vets
finally i have defined an open telemetry
collector
that actually gets spun up as well so
that these microservices can all report
to a locally running open symmetry
collector
that uses the collector.yaml file that i
just showed
for each of the micro services we have a
docker file
and in that docker file we will go ahead
and get the jar file from the open
symmetry project
so that we can embed it at runtime as a
parameter
and have it do by code manipulation of
our application
so that's about it and then what ends up
happening is
this microservices app gets fired up and
starts reporting traffic to an open
symmetry collector you can actually see
here
log lines of different spans already
being reported into the system
so just by firing it up we haven't even
accessed the ui yet you can see the data
is being generated and being sent to the
back ends of my choice
so i will go ahead and start up the pet
clinic application
you can see it's here we can go ahead
and look at let's say
any owners that are in the system any
veterinarians that are in the system
we can go ahead and add additional
information as well
you actually interact with the system in
multiple different ways and the net
result here is
in the case of zipkin we can go ahead
and
look for any traces that are coming into
the system
we can do this by service name so for
example maybe i'll go ahead and go take
a look at
discovery service and see that there are
actually traces coming into the system
and we can actually drill into these and
see
a variety of different calls are being
made and associated
metadata we can actually see this is
coming from the open telemetry project
as well now i've actually modified the
collector to also send to
the signalfx backend so here's another
example where again the data is being
sent to two different backends so i can
actually compare or i can send different
datas to different backends
really open symmetry is looking to be
vendor agnostic and provide a generic
way of handling instrumentation for you
so you can do it once and not have to
worry about it afterwards
so exact same data here as you can see
you get a visual topology
this basically represents what we saw in
the architecture diagram
of the github repo and as you can see i
made no
java changes in order to get this
instrumentation and actually
get some rich insights both from a
visual topology perspective
as well as my red metrics request error
and duration
and any other metadata that's associated
with it so that's a very quick demo on
how you can get started
with open telemetry both the auto
instrumentation
and the collector and without making any
code modifications only runtime
parameters were able to get some rich
telemetry data out of our application
thanks for the demo steve as i mentioned
in the beginning
there are already companies and groups
that are using open telemetry in
production services today
google is one of them starting back in
january we actually deployed the open
telemetry collector
into instances of google kubernetes
engine versions one point one six and
above
uh the open telemetry collector since
then has formed the backbone of the
metrics pipeline inside of gke
and replaced a number of deprecated
components like heapster
similarly we'll be using open telemetry
for cloud ops customers particularly
cloud monitoring and cloud trace
to replace the existing open
census-based sdks that they use to
capture
application metrics custom metrics and
distributed traces
next we're going to be using open
telemetry inside of google compute
engine
we have a new windows system monitoring
agent that's actually based on the open
telemetry collector
using a lot of the system monitoring
system metrics capabilities they talked
about during the introduction
beyond this we'll be using the collector
to replace our
linux monitoring agents uh probably
later this year or late or early next
year
and that will bring in the same
capabilities that we're bringing to
windows right now
at that point i think effectively all of
our metrics and tracing stack
will have been moved over to open
telemetry at least when it comes to
capturing data from customers
applications
at splunk we're also leveraging open
telemetry extensively
we basically have this broken up into
two different categories of work
internally we want to actually consume
and leverage open telemetry as much as
possible
so in the case of signal effects and
omniscient all of the infrastructure
today
is leveraging the open symmetry
collector in order to collect both
metrics and trace information
we're actually actively underway moving
to open telemetry client libraries
as well in order to get rich insights
and move to an open source
vendor agnostic and open standard way of
gathering telemetry data from our own
environments
externally we are active contributors to
the project we're actually maintainers
of the collector
as well as the java auto instrumentation
and we're working very closely with the
community to donate some of the signalfx
open source components around the smart
agent
gateway and other auto instrumentation
semantic conventions we've been working
on
finally we're about to get kicked off
with the net auto instrumentation sig so
if you're interested in that and really
want to get involved we'd love to
have your help all right next up let's
hear from francis about how
shopify is leveraging open telemetry
shopify is partway through a migration
from a custom trace collection
infrastructure to one based heavily
around open telemetry
in addition shopify is one of the
maintainers of the open telemetry ruby
client library
at present our architecture looks like
this
we have a large number of trace services
written in several languages and
instrumented in different ways
some of these are externally developed
such as core dns and nginx
some use our custom instrumentation and
export in its custom format
some exporting jaeges format some in
open census
some in zipkin
the open telemetry collector is the core
of our architecture
we add a couple of components to it in
particular a receiver for our custom
trace format and a custom exporter
our use cases for the collector include
pii reduction
down sampling for cost control adding
tags required by vendors
renaming spans to control cardinality
and fixing instrumentation flaws
here's an example of pii reduction in
the collector focusing mainly on
database queries attached to spans by
the instrumentation
but also with app specific redaction at
the top we redact any
database statement tags unless the span
also explicitly indicates that no pii is
present
lower down we identified the pii can
leak into the jawbox tag for this
service
so we explicitly redact those tags
so you just heard from a cloud provider
google a vendor
splunk and an end user shopify about
different experiences
leveraging open telemetry as you can see
there is broad support and broad
interest in this topic in fact open
telemetry has the
second most contributions in all of cncf
behind only kubernetes
that's pretty exciting and we would love
to have you come join us
you can get involved in the conversation
on gitter you can come join a special
interest group depending on which area
you care most about
and there are tons of great issues both
with help wanted
and good first issue labels it to get
you started
please come join the community please
come join the discussion as morgan
mentioned we're just getting started
with the logging specification
so if you're interested in logging now's
a great time to get involved in that as
well
we would love to have you be part of the
solution to this important problem for
the industry as a whole
and with that thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate it and
we hope to see you in the open symmetry
community soon
you